hello and welcome to this video gasp
playing gasps what GM said a GM they
don't know all right
we exchanged didn't get that so often in
recent games
yeah this line with Bishop e7 is
slightly questionable but it's one of
the very few ways to sometimes generate
to generate I had an idea with us with
this b3 move I should actually pay a
little bit of attention at least even if
you think the move is bad you can at
least try to figure out what the idea
was
yeah now I'm just eternally worse just
takes it okay
I mean it's not much fun there that u6
porn but I still would have thought he
[Music]
considers for a moment if he's got
something even better
[Music]
yeah this is going to be a long
suffering not sure how long maybe maybe
I'm losing quickly no Jim
it is quite quite obviously a bit of a
torture okay this is a little bit
helpful actually because now I can
advance the King and with the king
advanced I have slightly better chances
for activating at least one of the roof
so the king helps to defend a defenders
let's go
I wonder if King h6 as an idea looks
very very odd but my beam so I got the a
foul yeah he's going for it
he might be able to take it I mean it
looks it looks insane if you ask me but
[Music]
probably possible
I try rookie fate of seven here or of
seven immediately but we kidding me
really why is that
come on check
now how do we win this king f6 yeah
threatens rook h8 mate yes that's it
method this just made I asked to play
rook takes is 6m it was really a bit
weird just to go to h7 I mean really
white was just completely in control and
better after my terrible opening yeah
now here yeah just think a little bit
yeah 90 f6 is just atrocious
alright the engine actually doesn't
dislike it so much but it's just I
should be aware that this is a move yeah
and now I mean this in this really
awkward position I was surprised that he
just took it I mean it is definitely
better for Wyatt
after the capture but I would have I
wouldn't have been so sure it engine
absolutely agrees okay I can I can
barely cover it so now I have covered it
I'm not losing the pony melee and I was
surprised I think when g5 helps me
considerably because then after we trade
I can get the King closer and of course
it's still better for white but here I
think my defending um chances would be
should be quite reasonable and now he
started this this king when you were
king of seven and he just grabbed it
yeah
and it seems to work I mean it seems to
absolutely work the computer laughs said
but what cannot be done as probably rook
takes d5 so here I don't have enough
remarkable
now if the engine doesn't see anything
here it just doesn't work for me
and now I'm winning if he takes check
and we got the same story
oops
it's so it is extremely greedy to go to
h7 I mean maybe it's objectively good
but if he would have just pressed yeah
with this nice advantage I think it
would have been a lot easier to play and
very very one-sided my position it's
just you're going to be eternally worse
him eternity was okay guys thanks for
watching